la décision de la cour d'appel de dijon
était très attendue aujourd'hui
un mois après à la bagarre à saint
vallier en saône et loire entre deux
hommes sur fond de différend amoureux
l'un des deux jamal 39 ans était mort
étouffé son agresseur comparaissait
aujourd'hui devant la cour d'appel de
dijon pour statuer dans sa remise en
liberté sous contrôle judiciaire décidée
quelques heures après le drame le
procureur lui demander son placement en
détention
la cour d'appel a décidé aujourd'hui de
laisser l'agresseur vincent la
quarantaine également libres sous
contrôle judiciaire
l'audience s'est déroulée à huis clos
une demande de l'avocat général et
l'avocat de la famille des victimes
avait demandé lui aux proches de jamin
de ne pas venir à l'audience pour ne pas
envenimer les choses
il se dit déçu de la décision déception
des champions quand même parce
qu'effectivement pour des crimes de ce
genre
neuf fois sur dix ou même 99 fois sur
100 la personne est placée en détention
pour permettre une instruction sereine
là c'est pas le cas
j'en prends quelques jours après le
drame un centre social à montceau les
mines d'où la victime est originaire
avait été incendié et des mots taguées
sur les murs justice pour jamal pas sûr
que cette décision de la cour d'appel de
dijon aujourd'hui n'apaise la colère de
la famille l'enquète va maintenant se
poursuivre elle devrait durer un an